have you got a request to do the 9-1-1
calls reaction did you do that yeah I
actually did I did do that one and I
seen what you said in the video about
why you didn't do it I didn't I've never
thought of it like that when I was asked
to do the reaction I just did it because
I don't know but it yeah I never thought
about it like that yeah my you see the
thing is my number one philosophy with
YouTube is to tend to your subscribers
so I feel I feel bad about not posting
my reaction but I was doing it with a
friend of mine named Selena and Selena
had to leave halfway through the video
because she was getting so disturbed you
see a lot people think I just did it by
myself or something but she was she was
so disturbed by it and it just made me
feel horrible it was really disturbing
me because like a couple of years ago my
dad died 10 days later my grandma dies
there's another shitty thing that
happened that year but it wasn't death I
have friends I have one friend in
particular who had three friends died in
the matter of three months and I'm not
gonna reveal him but that was it for me
like when I said to them like it's a
personal reason why I'm not posting it
everyone suddenly goes you're a [ __ ]
Ryan like what the [ __ ] are you talking
like because of a serious amount of
trauma I know of there's a personal
reason as to why I'm not gonna post it
so because people are always like Ryan's
really edgy Ryan's really controversial
Ryan's this he'll say whatever he wants
he's mean like I have this like weird
reputation about that and then the
second I don't post something people are
like runs just trying to look like a
good guy when all I've tried doing was
explaining myself that hey this is not
something I am okay with doing and I
have no problem that you posted yours I
have no issue at all but man that was
just for me though yeah I understanding
a lot of subscribers or at least for the
most part should understand like and
respect your decision because you can't
post everything you can see because
sometimes it's not always the best thing
to do but yeah I guess that just shows
like your side a hopefully people
understand that when they see you
hey baby wants to head on Dante
she's cleaning kitty poop but she'll be
here in a second where are you born in
California you move there I was born I
was born at Kaiser Permanente and Van
Nuys California so yeah I grew up in
California it's been my life you know
like it's funny most people out here
wish they could live somewhere else I
personally love it because one thing I
love about this country America for
those you don't know with America
there's such a bunch of diversity and
with cultures everywhere and I think
California is a great example of that
sure we have one of the most populated
states with gangsters but other than
that it's pretty cool yeah that's not
smart do that anyway no good man
good well ya know I grew up I grew up in
LA and I think la is a wonderful spot to
be creative and work together and
develop a lot of things and and a lot of
people drink and smoke weed out here so
yeah right okay so what are your future
plans for your channel like do you plan
on adding a new series or particularly
the older series that you made stock or
anything that you see I'm starting up a
second channel called reel to reel
rejects because a lot of people don't
know this but I write a lot I do a lot
of stories like I'm constantly creating
stories and I write a lot of music too
so a lot of people don't know that [ __ ]
about me so that channel is gonna be
there to show random creativity stuff
it's gonna be a experimental channel
because all my short films and sketches
and the real rejects are all based in
the in the world of the real rejects so
like I'm always Ryan right Veronica's
always Veronica so I want to do more of
those short films and sketches I
actually do rap and I can actually and I
want to do some comedy rap and I thought
that'd be fun to show on there I'm
trying to get more movie related
discussions on there like personally
myself because because I know you do
movie reviews too for my personal
opinion towards me what makes my
reaction channel different is I really
take the time to for most of the videos
I say about 95 percent of the videos
really take the time to make sure
giving worthwhile opinions after the
reaction is done or at least providing a
good comedy its comedy or worthwhile
opinions after the video is done yeah
because I think a lot of people just
sort of end their video and I like to I
like to really give life after thoughts
and stuff which I think a lot of people
don't do I notice that recently your
videos have you thought about doing
gaming I have but the thing is I would
only do it because fans wanted me to the
thing is the gaming community it's
honestly not my passion I love games and
but I'm not as up-to-date with games as
I'd like to be or as people want me to
be but I'm just not up to date with it
and it's not because it's not much of a
passion of mine so I could throw in
opinions and stuff but the fact that
it's not a passion of mine I just
wouldn't want to commit to something
that I would feel like I'm only doing
for other people because it's like what
tending to your subscribers and tending
to your fans and all that you kind of
gotta meet them halfway you know like it
has to be something you really want to
do and something they really want from
you as well but right now people really
want it for me but I don't really want
it for myself seeing as how your movie
guys what are three movies that you can
sit down and watch over and over again
oh that's [ __ ] [ __ ] the departed I've
seen that like 12 times
that's that rare drama that I feel like
I can watch over and over again and I
learned something new every time I watch
it I've seen anchorman a billion times
I'm trying to think of a movie that I
could still to this day keep watching
and not get bored of it Terminator 2 and
or the matrix I think there's a lot Kill
Bill there's a video out that came two
days ago talking about how we act
there's our [ __ ] or whatever I saw that
yeah I'm good how are you good I don't
have any makeup on right now so I kind
of look messy leave me alone Thanks hey
you're awesome congratulations on your
YouTube success I see that you're at
your channels been growing rapidly so
and you have really you're funny and you
got great content so congrats on them we
want a threesome with you on counter we
wanted how do you feel about the hate
that reactors everyone who everyone who
makes comments about it or makes videos
about it first off it's it's [ __ ]
honestly it's [ __ ] stupid because
these people are going out of their way
to make videos about it like oh dude and
I'm like you wouldn't have a [ __ ]
video if we weren't doing these [ __ ]
videos and the fact that you're like no
they don't make all it's like you're
making views and money generating subs
off of the fact that we exist so yeah
that's one thing right there secondly
most of the time I could see whether it
coming from thirdly I think for anyone
who actually does frequent reaction
videos who actually does them they'll
know if that it's a little bit different
than what people perceive it to be like
it takes a while
first like I've brought people on this
channel who are like oh that's easy we
could just watch a video then talk about
it
but the second that camera [ __ ] turns
on they they freeze you know and they're
they're become too aware of what they're
doing and they're like are people gonna
think I'm faking it how do I just be
here and be real people who watch
reaction videos things like they want
you to just watch it as if you're
[ __ ] alone by yourself you know so
they wanted to be very real and so it
takes a certain type of emotional
process I think to be able to just
really be in the moment and be yourself
well you got lights and a camera pointed
at that's hard you know like and if you
talk to actors actors are constantly
saying that that's like one of the
hardest things to get past is people
looking at you camera and lights so it
is different when you're doing it
secondly there's a it's like to say that
people they don't deserve it in bla bla
bla bla bla obviously the reason why
reactors are getting success is because
people [ __ ] love it for some reason
whether whatever reason it may be people
are coming to watch a genuine
personality people are coming to hang
out with you it's a hangout like these
reaction channels our hangout channels
they're kind of like a podcast in a way
like a video podcast in some fashion you
know like it's I think it's really silly
that I could see why cuz honestly when I
first heard we're trailer reactions were
I thought it was a stupidest [ __ ]
thing ever so I totally get it if
someone doesn't do it I see why they
would be upset when they watch other
people's reactions where it's like where
it is like the same thing every time
it's very routine they don't offer
something different they're faking stuff
see if you're looking at that kind of
[ __ ] but honestly there's probably about
like I don't know how many like 6 to 8
channels that have popular reactions on
them but there's like way way more than
just that there's a billion people doing
a reaction channels now and the thing is
is that not every one of them is going
places because there's a few key things
to making it work and it's right it's a
lot more than what people actually
perceive it as like I'm sure you know
about this already they want a quality
video and most people focus on okay I
want to provide YouTube's quality videos
the thing that happens though is they
end up posting like once a week or once
a month whatever the thing with reaction
channels is they want quality videos but
they also want quantity they don't want
a video if you post a video once a week
and you have reactions people will get
pissed off of you and think you're
slowing down and lagging you have to
post several videos a week like you have
to if you're if you're going to make
this particular genre work so people
think not a lot of work goes into it
that's not true I spent about like 4 to
6 hours in every day of the week just
strictly on YouTube and it's usually
even more than that so the fact that
people are seen because there's more
than just putting a video together whose
other stuff do